مرحبا مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه للتحليل
العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على غزه معنا
فيها اللواء فايز الدويري مرحبا بك وارحب
ايضا بالزميل محمود الكن والذي معه نبدا
في قراءه للخريطه التفاعليه البدايه من
اليمن محمود نعم محمد يبدو ان الاوضاع
تزداد تعقيدا من الناحيه هنا الجيو سياسيه
على الاقل في الخطوط البحريه اذا ما
شاهدنا هنا هذه هي مواقع
لسفن الحربيه على الاقل بحسب المصادر
المفتوحه حتى يوم امس سنشاهد ان هناك
خليطا من الدول تتواجد هنا الولايات
المتحده قوات التحالف الصين بريطانيا وحتى
لايران وذلك يمتد حتى اذا ما توجهنا الى
ميناء ايلات هناك هناك البوارج الحربيه من
ساعر بالتالي نحن نعن وهنا بذل لك نحن
نشاهد قوه التحالف للولايات المتحده
وفرنسا وبريطانيا لها وجود هنا وكذلك
نشاهد لايران بالتالي نحن ربما نشاهد هنا
بعد اعلان هذا التحالف من عشر دول زياده
في الاحتكاك على مستوى القوات البحريه هنا
ستكون منطقه جيوسياسيا ساخنه على الاقل في
المدى المنظور الان نتوجه الى قطاع
غزه هنالك تحديثات في قطاع غزه يبدو ان
المناورات الاسرائيليه وسياسه التوغل بدات
تاخذ شكلا مختلفا كما نشاهد هنا باللون
الاصفر زياده في التوغ كانت على ما يبدو
هي تشبه التصريحات السياسيه التي تتحدث عن
مرحله ما بعد الحرب محاوله تكوين منطقه
التوغل هنا سنشاهد هذا العمق بدا ياخذ من
وسط القطاع هذه مناطق جديده في التوغل
باتجاه المخيمات
باتجاه البريج وا طبعا قبل الصيرات نحن
نتحدث عن المنطقه الشرقيه فقط بالتالي
هناك دفع من الجهه الشرقيه في الشمال وفي
الوسط محاوله للتوسع وتبدو وكانها تتكامل
ل تحدث شريطا حدوديا يبلغ عمله عمقه حوالي
كيلومتر واحد دعوني اتجه اليها بشكل اقرب
هنا في
الشمال سنشاهد هنا في الشمال اذا ما قسنا
هذه
المسافه نتحدث عن كر و300 متر اي تقريبا
وهذه هي اطراف حي الشجاعيه في هذه النقطه
تحاول القوات الاسرائيليه التوغل والدفع
باتجاه ساحه فلسطين كنا ايضا كتائب القسام
كانت قد ذكرت بانها التحمت مع القوات
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
التوغل والمناورات على شرق البريج
والمغازي نتحدث عن هذه النقطه اذا ما قصنا
من جحر الديك هنا سنشاهد بان هذه المنطقه
نحن نتحدث عن عرض حوالي 6 كيلومترات لكن
ننتبه الى العمق والمناطق الخاليه هذا
بحدود كيلومتر و700 متر اذا ما طبقنا
التصريحات السياسيه مع التولات العسكريه
يبدو تغيرا في الاستراتيجيه
الميدانيه في هذا الشان وخاصه واننا نسمع
عن استهدافات بالطيران في هذه النقاط ايضا
بالنسبه لجنوب قطاع
غزه
هنا مازال الضغط مستمرا لكن الوضع ما يزال
في حاله اتزان هنا ما يزال وبحسب صور
الاقمار الصناعيه التي صدرت خلال الايام
الاخيره الضغط من شارع كيسوفيم باتجاه
محور صلاح الدين هذا النقاط ما زال الضغط
من الجهه الشماليه الجهه الجنوبيه هي من
شارعين رئيسيا في عبسان الصغيره
وبسانيو جد عمليه تطويق كامله حتى هذه
اللحظه و حسب المعطيات على الاقل بالنسبه
لخان يونس هذه كانت بالنسبه لنا ابرز
التطورات محمد والمزيد من التحليل العسكري
عن هذا التغير في التوغل معكما انت
واللواء سنتحدث نعم عن شكل الخريطه الجديد
في
غزه اللواء فاس زويري قبل ذلك هنالك تطور
اليوم اطلاق الصواريخ من جديد من غزه تصل
الى تلبيب
الكبرى بعد
74 يوما من الحرب كيف تقراها يعني بعد 74
يوم يتم اطلاق رشقه صاروخيه على منطقه
واسعه تلبيب الكبرى مطار اللد
وشرق وج جنوب تل ابيب هذا اذا اردنا ان
نحلل ما جرى يجب ان ننظر له من بعدين
البعد الاول من جانب
المقاومه المقاومه عندما تطلق هذه
الصواريخ هي تبعث برسائل عسكريه ورسائل
سياسيه اولا ابدا بالرساله السياسيه
المقاومه تقول لا ازال قادر على استهداف
مركز الثقل السكاني الاقتصادي التجاري
وقادر على حجز ما يزيد عن مليون من
المجتمع الكيان الاسرائيلي واجبره على
الذهاب الى الملاجئ اذا كما فعلت في
بدايات المعركه بعد 74 يوم انا من يقرر
متى وكيف واين هذه الرساله السياسيه
عسكريه الرساله العسكريه كيف تستطيع
المقاومه ان تطلق هذه الرشق الصاروخيه بعد
74 يوم اذا لم يكن هيئه ركن العمليات لا
تزال تضبط ايقاع المعركه من حيث الزمان
والمكان وتختار الوقت المناسب تختار نوع
الصواريخ المناسب تختار الهدف المناسب اذا
هيئه ركن عمليات لا تزال فاعله هذا يعني
ان منظومه العمل المنظومه العمليات بدءا
من السياق الاعلى حتى مستوى الجماعات
الصغرى التي تنفذ ونشاهد الفيديوهات لا
يزالوا يعملوا هذا يتطلب الوفره الوفره
والقدره الوفره ساتي على ذكرها الان انا
اتحدث عن البعد التخطيطي وعن اليه اداره
المعركه لا يمكن لهذه الصواريخ ان تطلق
دون قرار من المستوى الاعلى في قياده حماس
لانها لها ارتداداتها السياسيه والعسكريه
اذا المستوى الاعلى من القياده هو من يتخذ
القرار يمرر القرار عبر سلسله قياديه الى
الجماعات المنفذه هذا ماذا يعني يعني ان
منظومه القياده والسيطره دائما نقول
الكوماند اند كنترول لكن الان اتحدث
منظومه القياده والسيطره اربعه
مستويات القياده السيطره الاتصالات
الكمبيوتر سي4 لا يزال يعمل بفاعليه والا
لن تستطيع اطلاق هذه الصواريخ الان بعد
انقطاع لفتره محدده وكانت الصواريخ تطلق
على غلاف غزه اثيرت تساؤلات كثيره وصلني
العديد من الرسائل سواء من الذباب
الالكتروني وغيره يسالوني اين صواريخ
القسام انا لا اعرف اين صواريخ القسام انا
كمحلل ولكن القسام هو الذي اعطاني الاجابه
الان من خلال الرشق الصاروخيه كانه يقول
مخزونات بخير لكنني انا من قرر متى وكيف
واين استخدمها وهنا سادخل في جزئيه من
التفصيل في تقرير تقارير سابقه لمراكز
صحفيه اعلاميه عالميه موثوقه عندما اتحدث
عن النيويورك تايمز وال واشنطن بوست كان
تقرير واضح جدا وقراته نيويورك تايمز في
نهايه سيف القدس تحدثت ان ما يملكه القسام
لا اتحدث عن بقيه الفصائل يقدر ب 50 الف
صاروخ من مديات مختلفه الواشنطن بوست في
نفس الاسبوع قدمت تقرير اخر تحدثت عن 3
الف صاروخ لنذهب الى المستوى الادنى
القسام من اسوار القدس لم يطلق ولا صاروخ
واحد حتى السابع من اكتوبر حتى في
الاعتداءين الذين حدثا وضد الجهاد
الاسلامي القسام لم يشترك في المعركه
اشترك في غرفه العمليات اذا اذا اخذنا من
حديث الواشنطن بوست وتجاهلنا مده عامين من
الاعداد والتحضير والتصنيع لديه 3000
صاروخ كم اطلق 13000 صاروخ تقريبا اذا لا
يزال عندما يتحدث المتحدث سواء في الداخل
او في الخارج لدينا القدره على الاستمرار
لاشهر نعم لديهم القدره على الاستمرار
لاشهر حت حتى ننتقل الى الخريطه لماذا
استخدمت اسرائيل قبل ذلك لماذا استخدمت
اسرائيل منظومه مقلاع قبل الخريطه مقلاع
داوود في اعتراض هذه الان
هناك ثلاثه مستويات للدفاع الجوي في في
اسرائيل تبدا من القبه الحديديه مقلاع
داوود ومن ثم ارو
حيتس الان هذا مرتبط بمدى الصاروخ القادم
عندما يكون الصاروخ مدى من 5 الى 70 م
تتعامل معه القبه الحديديه اذا كان المدى
ابعد من ذلك لانه يكون المحرك اعلى تذهب
الى مقلاع داوود عندما تاتي طائره مسيره
او صاروخ بالستي من الحوثيين في اليمن
تستخدم السهم اذا عمليه
تحديد نوعيه الدفاع الجوي الذي يستخدم هو
مرتبط بنوعيه الصاروخ مدى الصاروخ يعني
كان ممكن الصواريخ اليوم تصل الى مديات
ابعد من تلبين الان اذا اردنا ان ندخل في
البعد الدقيق مدى صاروخ عياش كم 250
ك كريات الشونه كم تبعد 250 م ايلات
الرشراش سابقا كم تبعد 230 ك م اذا صواريخ
القسام اذا اخذنا عياش كصاروخ هو المدى
الاقصى يغطي فلسطين المحتله عندما نتحدث
عن كريات شبوه اين اتحدث عن اقصى شمال
فلسطين المحتله وعندما يتحدث عن ايلات نفس
الشيء طيب الان ننتقل الى الخريطه وتحدث
محمود عن
تغيير في في شكلها ربما ابرز تغيير هو
التموضع الال محاوله التقدم من المناطق
الشرقيه كما شاهدنا في الشمال الان نشاهد
في المحافظه الوسطى شرقي مخيمي البريج
والمغازي ما الذي تقراه في تواجد هذه
الاليات ومحاوله السيطره على المناطق
الزراعيه شرق المخيمات دعنا نتحدث عن
بعدين الان هناك
محاوله دخول مناطق جديده سواء في
الشريط لا اقول الحدودي السياج الفاصل في
منطقه الس سياج لانه يبدو لي من ط من
طريقه القصف وكثافه القصف ونوعيه القصف
وحركه الاليات كان جيش الاحتلال هكذا اقرا
يريد ان يسيطر على المنطقه السياج بعمق
يتراوح في حده الادنى 1300 بحده الاقصى
حسب المناطق 2 موم من بيت حانون حتى رفح
حتى يصل مع الحدود المصريه هو يريد وكان
هناك بعض التقارير وتم حديث ومن ثم لم يعد
التركيز عليها انه يسعى اصلا الى حفر خندق
ضد الدبابات على الحد الغربي منها واقامه
ساتر ترابي و وفرضها منطقه بفزون وبالتالي
لا اعتقد ان المقاومه يعني انا من الخارطه
احلل انهم هم لا يدركوا ما اقول لا هم
سابقين في هذه النقطه النقطه الاخرى يحاول
ان يحقق تدخلات خاصه في القطاعين الشمالي
والجنوبي لماذا هناك الان حديث واضح جدا
عن مقاربه سياسيه بغض النظر عن احتمال
نجاحها احتمال فشلها وقف اطلاق نار هدنه
انسانيه كل واحد يتحدث بطريقه لكن اعتقد
المسار واضح بالنسبه تقصد يريد فرض امر
واقع جديد هو الان عندما دخل الى ساحه
فلسطين هو يحاول ان اذا ما تم اذا ما
استطاع التثبت فيها الان هو يفرض واقع
جديد على ط
طوره التفاوض اذا هو الان يحاول بصوره
كبيره جدا الدفع بقوات جديده اذا ذهبنا
الى منطقه وادي غزه المغازي والبريج محمود
لو سمحت معن معى الخريطه مخيمات بس يعني
فقط وا نعم الان اذا تحدثنا هذه المنطقه
اللي اشار الها محمود الان لو اشرنا بس من
اجل المشاهد وادي غزه لاحظ هذا الاندفاع
الجنوبي عندم البريج والمغازي والنصيرات
هو يحاول هذا دفع بقوات جديده ليست القوات
التي تقاتل في الشجاعيه ولا القوات التي
تقاتل في جحر الديك هو لديه بحدود سته فرق
ليست كلها داخل غلا داخل غزه قسم منها
الخارج في غلاف غزه هو دفع وحدات جديده
طازجه من اجل تحقيق هذا التمدد وسيسعى
للاتجاه جنوبا لانه طبيعه الارض تصلح
لقتال الدبابات وبالتالي هو ي حاول ان
تصبح هذه الخريطه الصفراء ممتده حتى تص
تصل الى اقصى الجنوب ويسيطر على هذه
المنطقه كذلك يحاول اذا لو سمحت محمود
تنزل الخارطه الجزء
الشمالي القاطع الشمالي عندما نتحدث
القاطع الشمالي محمود لو
سمحت الان اذا اذا نظرنا عند كلمه غزه هذه
هي ساحه فلسطين في هذه المنطقه هو دخلها
على فكره ثلاث مرات قبل قبل الهدنه نعم
واخرج منها و وحدث انه القسام قدم او سلم
الرهائن مرتين في هذه الساحه هو الان
يحاول ان يدخل مره اخرى الان لاحظ المسافه
من السياج الى الحدود القصوى التي وصلها
بحدود 4 كيلو الا 3 كيلو و660 متر الان
المسافه الفاصله قصيره جدا قد تقدر بحوالي
1 ك م الى او ما شابه ذلك هو ي حاول اذا
استطاع ان ان ان يق 2 ك تقريبا نعم تقريبا
2 م يعني هو الان يحاول ان
تلتقي المناطق الملونه وبالتالي هو يقسم
يقسم الان لاحظ يقسم الزيتون وجحر الديك
عن الشجاعيه وجباليا اذا هو يعتمد نظريه
تجزئه المجزا لانه هذا يساعده ان لم
يساعده عسكريا واشك انه سيساعده لان هي
مناطق كثافه سكانيه مناطق التقتيل لكن هو
يحاول ان يفرض امرا واقعا في يسير بموازاه
المفاوضات التي او الحديث الذي يجري حول
هدنه انسانيه او وقف اطلاق نار لانها
ستكون اوراق قوه له على طاوله التفاوض
لننتقل الان الى ما نشره جيش الاحتلال وهو
فيديو جديد قال جيش الاحتلال انها مشاهد
للمعارك في الشجاعيه ويعلن عن مقتل تسعه
من ضباطه وجنوده في معارك غزه ايضا اعلن
عن اصابه 29 وذلك طبعا حصيله يوم واحد
ارتفع بذلك عدد القتلى من الجيش منذ بدء
العمليه البريه الى
137 هذا الفيديو دكتور ونحن نتابع يعني ما
ينشره الجيش من من من معارك في المقابل
القسام يعلن عن استهداف لاليات وان كانت
مثلا في منطقه اخرى مثل الشيخ رضوان ما
الذي تقراه من هذه الصور ومن اعلان القسام
عن التصدي لابد لابد ان نع يعني نقرا او
نلقي نظره على الفيديوهات من من الطرفي
المقدم اذا ذهبنا الى الفيديوهات القسام
او الجهاد الاسلامي المثلث الاحمر والمثلث
الاصفر نتحدث دائما او نشاهد صوره كامله
لمعركه فيها طرفي الصراع طرفي القتال
يعطيك المقاتل سواء من الجهاد او القسام
يعطيك الهدف يعطيك لحظه الاطلاق يعطيك
النتيجه اذا ذهبنا الفيديوهات التي تقدم
من قبل جيش الاحتلال انت تنظر الى احد شقي
المعادله طرف اخر لا يوجد طرف اخر عمليه
هذه كانه يصور في في مدينه التدريب في
صحراء النقب كيف يطلق النار كيف يهاجم كيف
يتحدث وبالتالي هذه الفيديوهات من وجهه
نظر عسكريه انا كمحلل اعتبرها فتره
استراحه بالنسبه لي عندما انظر لها يعني
لا داعي لاشغال فكري كثيرا لاصل الى نتيجه
حتميه اذا دخول الاليات الخارطه واضحه جدا
اين دخل وما هي المناطق التي دخل فيها
خلال 24 ساعه حقق تقدمات يعني من حيث
دخوله الى مناطق جديده لكن نعود الى
التواجد والى مدى السيطره والتثبت وعلى
ذكر ذلك اليوم في الشيخ رضوان اعلان
القسام انه استهدف عربه همر بصحبه الاليات
كذلك في تل الزعتر يا سيدي [__] تل الزعتر
جرافه ناي استهدف ما اطلق عليه ناقله نعم
تسمى همر واستهدف جرافتين وبالتالي كذلك
في في المنطقه الجنوبيه هناك معارك ضاريه
اذا هناك استهدافات انا اقول لك عندما
تحشد هذا الكم من
القوه امام
مقاتلين افراد
باسلحه قصيره المدى لكنها فاعله لا يمكن
انا لا يمكن لي ان اوقف الدبابه بجسدي انا
اوقف الدبابه بالمعدات الموجوده انا لست
في حرب نظاميه فرقه مدرعه امام امام لواء
مدرع بمعنى هذا العدد سيدخل هذا العدد يجب
ان يدخل يجب ان يدخل حتى بدون اطلاق نار
يستطيع ان يدخل بدون بدون القصف التمهيد
والتدمير والمجازر التي تعد بالالاف
يستطيع الدخول لكن هل يستطيع التثبت هل
يستطيع البقاء الا يجبر على الانسحاب
واعاده الانتشار والتموضع هذا هو مهم اذا
الدخول وكيف نفسر هذا العدد من الخسائر في
احدث
واهم واكثر الاليات تقنيه وتصفيح الان هذه
ندخل في في في حديث اخر عندما نتحدث عن
التقنيات ونظام التروفي وما شابه ذلك
بالامس نظام تروفي منع القسام من ان يطلق
صاروخ الكورنيت على ال الناقلات الجند
لماذا لانها محميه بنظام التروفي او ال
المعطف او الستره الواقيه معطف الريح او
الستره الواقيه او ترفي ثلاثه اسماء لديه
نظام دفاع متكامل من الرشاشات من الصواريخ
من القنابل الدخانيه من اجهزه الاستشعار
لديها القدره على تحديد الهدف ومواجهته
لكن في حال ما نتحدث عن الياسين ونتحدث عن
التي بي جي ونتحدث هذه مديات قصيره الحد
الاقصى 130 متر لسرعتها تستطيع وصول من
لحظه الاطلاق الى الهدف في اقل من ثانيه
وبالتالي نظام التروفي غير فاعل امامها
لهذا السبب نجد
ان لكن هذا النظام في خانيونس لم يعمل في
في ميركافا اربعه فشل في التصدي لماذا انا
اتحدث عن مسافه سبيس اند تايم انا اتحدث
عن 130 متر مدى لياسين وبالتالي هذا المدى
وسرعه الصاروخ يقطع المسافه في اقل من
ثانيه نظام تروفي لا يستطيع ان يكتشفه
وبالتالي جاءت نقطه يعني تم استغلال نقطه
الضعف من
خلال الوقت والمسافه ل قانص الدروع في
مجموعات القسام والجهاد الاسلامي لهذا
السبب
نرى العدد الكبير من الخسائر والفيديوهات
تثبت ذلك لكن لاحظ بالامس عندما كان
الاطلاق من مسافه قد تكون اكثر من 4 كيلو
متر لم يستخدم الرامي صاروخ الكورنيت ضد
الناقلات اثر ان يستهدم يستهدف سياره
الجيب لماذا لانها غير محميه بنظام تروفي
بينما كان هناك احتمالا لنظام تروفي هذه
الصوره كان نظام تروفي هناك احتمال عالي
ان يسقط صاروخ
الكورنيت فلذلك استهدفوا الجيب الع استهدف
الجيب وهذا كان نوع من الذكاء والثقافه
العسكريه لدى الجندي يعني هذا المقاتل
لديه
معرفه هناك قدرات لهذه المعدات وهناك
قدرات للصاروخ الذي انت تمتلكه فعليك ان
توظف مزايا صاروخك لتجاوز التقنيه
المتقدمه هنالك سؤال لماذا تدخل هذه
الجبات او الهامر ما يسمى بنقله الجند الى
هذه المناطق وهي تعلم انها مستهدفه 100%
بالامس بالامس ابراج النى ماذا تح حدثوا
قالوا بانها منطقه دانت وتحت
السيطره جاء الفيديو الذي قدم بعد الاعلان
من قبل جيش الاحتلال بساعه واثبت ان هذا
الاعلان ليس دقيقا وليس صحيحا هو يرى
عندما تتوقف العمليات الان بيت حانون وجحر
الديك هي افضل امثله يمكن ان نقدمها لانها
مناطق دخلها في اليوم الاول واحنا الان في
اليوم ال 7بس من المعركه احنا في اليوم ال
50 من المعركه البريه الفارق الفارق 24
يوم ما بين بدء الحمله الجويه وما بين بدء
الحمله البريه نحن في اليوم ال 50 الان
جحر ديك و بيت حانون دخلها في اليوم الاول
نعم الان تحدث فيها عمليات لكن لا تحدث
العمليات يوميا لن تتبع الاحداث تحدث كل
ثلاث كل اربع ايام كل خمس ايام كل اسبوع
تكون هناك عمليه ناجعه ناجعه اذا هي ليست
تحت السيطره لكن دائره او حريه التصرف
للمقاتل بدات تضيق بسبب كثره تواجد القوات
وبالتالي الان مخارج الانفاق قد تكون ضمن
المواقع والفيديو الذي نشر وظهر من من بين
الخيم هذه احد الامثله اذا تواجد القوات
وتثبتها يحدد اطار حريه العمل والتصرف
للمقاتل شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء فايز دوير
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اشكر زميلي
محود الكن ايضا الذي رفقنا في هذه الفقره
التحليليه